studying new developments in the case of
Harvey Weinstein as more victims come
forward today Hollywood a-listers
Gwyneth Paltrow and Angelina Jolie said
they have been sexually assaulted by the
disgraced Hollywood mogul all this comes
as disturbing new audio is released of
the studio boss caught in a sting
operation by police and an Italian
actress
Jonathan hunt joins us with the latest
Jonathan Jesse the allegations just keep
coming Gwyneth Paltrow and Angelina
Jolie both telling the New York Times
Harvey Weinstein sexually harassed them
when they were young and starting out in
Hollywood The New Yorker magazine
separately reporting allegations of rape
and for the first time we're hearing
that audio of what the New Yorker claims
is Harvey Weinstein pressuring a young
actress to join him in his hotel room as
she complains about being groped here's
more of that now we should point out
that tape was part of a 2015 police
sting operation in New York and the
Manhattan DA's office ultimately
declined to pursue charges in the case
the DA's office in fact has just put out
a statement in the last few minutes on
Twitter saying that that audio quote was
insufficient to prove a crime under New
York law meantime the chorus of
condemnation of Weinstein is getting
louder Nicole Kidman and George Clooney
among the latest to speak out and former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton who
once considered the movie mogul a
political supporter issued a statement a
couple of hours ago saying quote I was
shocked and appalled
by the revelations about Harvey
Weinstein the behavior described by
women coming forward cannot be tolerated
their courage and the support of others
is critical in helping to stop this kind
of behavior now Jessie interesting to
note that like the Clintons the Obamas
were also close to Harvey Weinstein we
have not yet heard from President or
mrs. Obama who once described Harvey
Weinstein as a quote wonderful human
being that was at the White House in
2013 Jessie thanks Jonathan
all right Kimberly when you hear the
audiotape of wine stand just disgusting
what do you think about that well I can
imagine the Manhattan DA's office yeah
is very frustrated because when you see
that and as having worked as a
prosecutor and worked in sexual assault
cases it's appalling it's a disgusting
behaviors that's not just some kind of
allegation you hear the tape there as
well and so this is something that they
should open a broader investigation into
especially with more people coming
forward to determine whether or not
there can be any further charges made in
a case like based off of that tape you
might be able to revisit that you could
depending where that happened what are
the limitations in places like New York
and Los Angeles these are very serious
allegation I'm not talking about women
who were able to pass up some of his
advances you're talking about the most
serious allegations of sexual assault
and rape here so what are the statute of
limitation law depending they'd be able
to bring the case depending on where it
occurs so there's separate
investigations and finding out what time
how many times it happened some of them
they might be able to prosecute one or
two instances they may not be able to
prosecute if others are further back
it's very similar in terms of what we
saw with Bill Cosby's case right so
you're gonna have to determine that but
this tape in particular I think it's
interesting because she's referring to a
previous incident the day before where
she was actually physically touched like
we sexual battery sexual assault he
seems to acknowledge that right and so
there's a statement against interest
there that would come in that would be
admissible you'd be able to play that
tape on in court that whole type of
thing and bring it in front of the judge
and Kennedy Hillary waited five
days to come out and condemn this guy
yeah so long because you know
unfortunately this is how the system
works in politics and in entertainment
and Harvey Weinstein for years for
decades had a stranglehold on both he
did something very interesting and you
know Kimberly I'm sure you've taken note
of this he hired Lisa bloom you know I
said as a tutor but also here's a woman
who normally she handles sort of class
action very high profile sexual abuse
sexual assault cases as you know Gloria
Allred has done the same thing Harvey
Weinstein made sure that he hired her so
she would have to recuse herself so she
wouldn't be able to parade a dozen women
before cameras and I think that was very
intentional on his part and it's all
part of the cycle again something in
production I used to also he had options
one of her books exactly something else
that's part of the the cycle is abuse
they cycle of abuse that you just
pointed out is something that's
happening again I think in this case
we've seen it in other high-profile
cases this year I want to take care to
point it out we're getting reactions now
from Hollywood celebrities people that
have been working with him for decades
some of some of them people like George
Clooney and Jennifer Lawrence and
Angelina Jolie and the list goes on and
on and on a lot of folks who have spoken
out to condemn Harvey Weinstein do so
quite elint ly eloquently I'll cite
George Clooney who said straight up this
is indefensible the problem with a lot
of responses were seeing to me comes
from the things they say after they call
him out George Clooney himself did this
in his interview people like him and
Jennifer Lawrence say that they have not
personally been witness or privy to any
of these behaviors from Harvey Weinstein
this is something we see all the time
and I don't know if there's a legal
basis for this here if there's legal
reasons like they're covering their
butts and that's why they include things
like this in their statement but it just
rubs me the wrong way that they will
take care to say they haven't seen it
when do people rape and sexually assault
victims in front of other people of
course you haven't seen this behavior of
course Harvey Weinstein didn't
ask a young woman to watch him take a
shower naked in front of somebody else
this happens in private perpetrators go
to great lengths to cover up their
crimes it's like when you're if you are
talking about a murderer in a court of
law well I never saw him murder you know
this is horrible but I never saw him
murder anyone that is it of course you
did very good
Richard also brought in some executive
assistants and things like that they
said to like lure people in to make them
feel like they weren't alone and
engaging this behavior which is just
classic sexual predator right serial
sexual predator if you look at all the
allegations over the course of the time
Richard people are saying that this
shows Hollywood hypocrisy that they
champion women's rights and they've
criticized Donald Trump in the past but
have been totally quiet for decades
about a guy right under their nose well
I think this is a broader problem that
we have in this country around I hate to
use the words but this ideal of rape
culture right and I think want I think
we commend these women for being brave
and speaking out and I think they're
worthy of commending but I think we have
to have a larger conversation not only
about commending zoom but how do we do a
better job of educating our men and boys
to not make these type of mistakes right
like how do we start having these
conversations earlier and earlier and
earlier about having accountability
within are you your human resource
department no I know you never let me
finish this point because this is
something that really strikes me about
this story you know who's brave the
intern or the assistant who's working in
that office for less than a year the
actress has never had a role who comes
forward and who knows their story is
going to be squashed by a press who is
complicit who has these book deals who
has these movie options and therefore
they're not going to report on the
stories the Matt Damon's of the world
who squashed the 2004 New York Times
story it's really easy for Gwyneth
Paltrow to come forward in 2017 when
it's safe to go ahead and tell this when
she has benefited from these
relationships for decades no great women
are the ones whose careers were
destroyed who were sent packing back to
the Midwest enemy self-esteem I agree
with you a hundred percent
but what I'm saying is and that's
probably got it also do with the supply
problem right which is we have men who
engage in this behavior over and over
again so how do we
stop it before it happens how do we
educate our boys not to make these
mistakes right how do moms have
conversation with their young boys about
this is how you treat women this is how
you don't treat women right this is what
he knows how to treat women he parsley
mystery I beg to differ George Clooney
said we have to do a better job at
protecting women in the workplace and
that is true but what all is also true
and what is needs to happen first is as
Richard says we need to do a better job
of teaching young men boys how to behave
and how not to behave I think that's the
point did the wrong thing
moms for it well no but he's saying to
just have education about it which is
important and to have training about it
so people know what is appropriate but
this is on a whole other level this goes
beyond like a gray area this guy is a
serial advisor we're not talking about
something being polite manners and how
you treat women we're talking about
somebody who appears to be a sexually
you know violent predator it's not
because of the culture he grew up in as
what's as Lisa bloom tried to claim in
her defense this is not cousins Andy's
when it was caught it was not
appropriate or okay to rape women in the
60s right a lot of men and women grew up
in the 60s and 70s and they don't go
around treating her like a disposable
object so let me get back to the
politics of it because now a lot of
people are being asked to return
donations some donations have been
returned and not all donations have been
returned at what point does all of his
money become dirty and you get rid of it
immediately well I know I was reading
early in our materials Julian you wrote
on an email we were talking about this
I'm it becomes then difficult to get
money back that's been spent who do you
get it from this politician Republican
politicians when you're saying you know
oh did he gave money to the Obamas or to
the Clintons if that campaign money's
been spent how are you supposed to
clawback something that doesn't exist
and that it's supposed to personally pay
the money out and then you know
everybody is expected to okay make a
statement Hillary Clinton make a
statement
but in to disavow the Obama's have not
made a statement to that point you just
made and malia it I think it was Malia
in terms of his company last year all
right everything that Shelly said he was
a good guy or a good friend too well I
guess they weren't that close friends
because she doesn't have any idea and
anybody else said they didn't have any
idea either so we'll say